I'll tell you we still got it on it oh
yeah yeah we do
true that Walden we hear oh yeah hey we
hittin Britney right now is visit we out
here straight hitting the bricks as it
were hey I'm gonna tell you right now I
got a pocket full of nickels and I'm
ready to get loose okay get another
round on guys like great great great
drink up we got great I'll sort it out
we got him Young Buck drink front dad
honey Ken Drake like Drake the rapper
he's a musician like starter phone to
bottom now we here
great great great oh no I'm you didn't
call it drink oh you know never never
mind
you guys are awesome great oh he'll be
your top rock creature okay you guys are
awesome no man no Drake I don't know
nothing about no Drake I tell you know
I'm trying to watch my calorie intake we
worry about no drinks earning about
digesting my steak Oh Drake Drake juice
on my corn flakes he talking about Gregg
trying to talk about great I need five
breaths to blow out my birthday cake
doesn't mean I ain't concerned about no
bakery you won't be concerned about
Drake that's all no time brother [ __ ]
man lost my teeth in a lake over here
like a 1930s cartoon hitting my head
when I step on a rake you took my dream
you concerned about weight I'm concerned
about making it the job without making a
bathroom mistake my left eyeball the
face sperm my testicles do not make I
woke up this morning in my booty hole a
great great
[Music]
look at it look at these two old-timers
over hell now dig it in your name water
are weird over that weird
Hey hello gonna y'all like break drink
hell yes
started from the bottom now the whole
team [ __ ] here
you're like Tyler the Creator
you